[MUSIC PLAYING]
AGV: Offering services
every day to thousands
and even millions of people
is an amazing challenge
from a scale perspective.
More specifically, take
workforce development programs
run by cities and states.
They are extremely important.
And as they support
so many people
with an array of
services that range
from job-matching opportunities,
personal development via job
coaching, self-service
resources, to just name a few.
And I have learned
a lot about how
running such meaningful programs
requires extensive coordination
across applicants, employers,
community partners, and sharing
knowledge broadly.
2020 brought many
challenges, especially
as in-person operations
were shut down
and many were left
vulnerable to unemployment.
The State of Rhode Island
responded to these challenges
by modernizing their workforce
development operations
and moving completely
to an online platform
called the Virtual
Career Center--
also nicknamed VCC.
It was developed in
partnership with Google Cloud
and a nonprofit called Research
Improving People's Lives.
And the VCC was fully built
by Google Cloud partner Maven
Wave.
As a quick intro, Maven
Wave helps a wide array
of organizations, including
public sector customers,
with many types of
cloud initiatives--
whether it's big
data and machine
learning, building
mobile applications,
helping design positive
online user experiences,
moving infrastructure
to the cloud,
or deploying collaboration tools
like email, chat, documents.
They even offer strategy
and technology advice.
Today, I've invited Joel
Osman from Maven Wave
to share more
about that journey.
Howdy, my friend.
Mind sharing a bit
about what you do?
JOEL OSMAN: So I lead the
Maven Wave digital experience
design--
our UX and design team-- as
well as our custom application
development practice.
And I am also the executive
sponsor for our Virtual Career
Center solution that we've been
bringing to market with Google.
AGV: Joel, for the
folks watching,
could you briefly share,
what was the specific use
case your team focused on?
JOEL OSMAN: So the primary
use case that we looked at
is, how can we apply
leading-edge, emerging
technologies to help
people get back to work?
And to use those
tools in such a way
that we can augment the
personal one-to-one interactions
that these agencies had
been using with job seekers
to help them get back to work.
AGV: That's beautiful.
Joel, can you touch upon
some of the products
it took to build the
Virtual Career Center?
JOEL OSMAN: The VCC comprises
a number of different Google
technologies.
Obviously, the custom
pieces that we're
building for scheduling,
for login authentication,
for data pipelines
and data analytics
are all in Google
Cloud platform.
And we're doing
custom builds there
that integrate into the
state's existing systems.
So we essentially
have taken things
like Google Meet, Google
Calendar, Google Docs--
so a lot of those core
tool sets that people
use in their
everyday lives, we've
wrapped them in this specific
use case around the Virtual
Career Center.
So when a job coach
is going online
to update their availability
of when they can hold sessions,
that's really happening, in the
background, in Google Calendar.
And when a job seeker
and a job coach
get together in a
video session, it's
actually happening
in Google Meet.
So those are really the engines
of technologies, if you will,
that are driving the
entire VCC experience.
AGV: Now, if you
don't mind, let's
do a quick walkthrough
of what I've learned
about your architecture.
And then I would like to
talk a bit more about some
of the design decisions
behind all of this.
For starters, end
users mainly interact
via an app built on
Angular as the frontend,
and it's connected to
backend services hosted
on Google Kubernetes Engine
or relevant Google Workspace
products, such as
Chat, Calendar, Meet,
Drive, and Docs.
From a user journey perspective,
there are three main types
of users at this time,
and that's job coaches,
job seekers, and employers.
Job coaches all have Google IDs
in the Google Workspace domain
and therefore authenticate
against the Google Identity
repository.
Job seekers are authenticated
through a Cognito-based process
maintained by the nonprofit
I mentioned earlier
with the Rhode
Island infrastructure
team and the Department
of information Technology.
For context, prior to the
start of the VCC project,
the state of Rhode Island was
making use of this Cognito
identity repository
to authenticate users
going through the unemployment
insurance application process.
And rather than adding an
additional identity repository
for users interacting
with the state,
the decision was
made to leverage
the existing Cognito
repository and its methods
of authentication.
In this release of the
Virtual Career Center,
employers participate
directly with Google Meet--
and to an extent,
Google Calendar--
but not the Angular app.
To touch upon some of the Google
Cloud components specifically,
let's start with
Firestore, which
is a real-time database
that keeps data in sync
across client apps.
It is used as the
primary persistence
tool for the web pages.
It also has a small role
to play with the login
process for job coaches.
Next is BigQuery, which is a
serverless warehouse for data,
which is why it
is used primarily
for reporting purposes.
Data Studio is used to build
filterable dashboards over it.
Then there are Cloud
Functions, which
are functions you can
trigger via snippets of code
and are used for a few
purposes in the solution,
such as populating jobs and
training data in the production
instance, ensuring
consistency between Google
Calendar and availability
data for job coaches,
and for populating BigQuery
on a scheduled basis.
Then there's the
Kubernetes cluster
on which server-side code
runs in a single region
deployment with a minimum
of four nodes per zone
across three zones of
the US East Region.
The cluster is set
to autoscale in order
to ensure that there is
sufficient processing
power in the event
that there are
spikes in activity on the site.
From a security
standpoint, there's
Cloud Armor, which protects
applications and websites
from attacks.
And in this specific
implementation,
there are several sets of
NIST-compliant policies--
such as geofencing--
which prohibits access
to the site from
outside of the US.
Content is accessed through
Google's content distribution
network, taking advantage of
caching wherever possible.
And finally, to
manage the lifecycle
of the infrastructure,
a Terraform script
is used, which is
an open-source tool
and is structured into
five folder environments.
Can you share a bit
more about, what
was the experience
like for users before
and after the Virtual
Career Center was launched?
JOEL OSMAN: Sure.
So in a sense, the
solution that we built,
it changes the way
job seekers interact
with the state and
the state agency.
Before the Virtual
Career Center,
interested people--
there was a website
and there were website resources
that people would utilize.
But it was very
much, in many states,
a hodgepodge of things--
the training opportunities.
There was often a
state database of jobs
that they could search into.
And there were some very
basic online capabilities.
But a lot of things
happened physically
in the Career Center.
There's a lot of that
face-to-face interaction
where coaches could really have
an impact and help job seekers.
And the challenge, when we
built the Virtual Career Center,
is how can we keep
that intimacy?
How can we keep that
collaborative nature?
And how can we dial
up the online tools,
in a sense-- because
in many respects,
we were forced to-- but try to
keep that tight interaction?
We strive to keep that
personal interaction.
And I like to say now, a job
coach can talk to a job seeker
on opposite ends of the
state and they can really
focus on getting
the right advice,
the right coach in front
of the right job seeker.
AGV: It's exciting
to me to see how
we can continue to
recreate these safe spaces
in a virtual format,
and on top of that,
create better alignment between
job coaches and job seekers
who have expertise in
navigating different services.
This is thanks to having more
robust ways for job seekers
to find coaches with
specific backgrounds,
such as coaches who have a
history with helping college
students.
And Joel, is there a
fun fact you could share
with us about the project?
JOEL OSMAN: Well, I can
share one interesting fact.
Before we launched the solution
with Rhode Island, which
was the initial Virtual Career
Center state that we deployed
in, we were a little
concerned about the adoption
from the career coaches.
They were already having to
deal with working from home.
We showed them what it
was going to be like.
We tried to do everything we
could to ease them into it.
And we did it with sort
of holding our breath.
What's going to come of this?
We were actually
pleasantly surprised.
They were absolutely
excited for the solution.
They were commenting how it's
really going to help them out.
They couldn't wait.
They were asking how
soon they can get it.
So it was kind of interesting.
I think we were overly--
not pessimistic.
We were more concerned of
what the reactions would be.
But they just embraced
it wholeheartedly
and were very excited.
And it got us very excited that
we are doing the right thing
and we've created
the right experience.
And just seeing them absolutely
pounce on the solution
was very gratifying.
AGV: Yeah.
I think that fear of
whether a new tool is going
to be well-received
or not, especially
amongst so much change
in the environment,
is extremely relatable
to IT practitioners.
And so your approach
is an excellent example
of how important it is to scope
time to collect user feedback
and to do it very early on
and as often as possible
when designing systems.
Another topic I want
to touch upon is data.
By having more data centralized
in a digital format,
there are greater opportunities
around analytics and insights.
What were some design
considerations with data?
JOEL OSMAN: We're working a lot
with data in the Virtual Career
Center solution.
In particular, we're
looking at analytics.
If we're going to implement
a solution like this,
key stakeholders in
the state, right up
to the governor's offices--
they want to know,
is it working?
Are people finding jobs?
Are people having
career sessions?
So there's a lot of
analytics to track
what's working and not working.
And we can do this in
a virtualized solution.
And we talk a lot about creating
analytics and dashboards,
not just for stakeholders
within the state who
are interested in how the
Virtual Career Center is doing,
but we talk a lot
about employers.
Because a lot of times,
employers are posting jobs
and want to use those
Virtual Career Centers
to connect to job seekers.
So we're talking about
an employer dashboard
so they can understand,
who's out there?
Who's the possible
candidate pool?
And how can they see
how the Virtual Career
Center can benefit them?
And we even talk about
personal dashboards.
AGV: Do you envision any
technical enhancements
in the future to
this architecture?
And is this solution only
for state and local entities?
JOEL OSMAN: So the
Virtual Career Center--
or the VCC, as we
call it-- is actually
comprised of three pillars,
is the way we talk about it.
One is around modernizing
digital experiences.
And this is taking what is, for
many states, an older design,
older set of
technologies that they
used for very basic
online functionality,
and giving that all a new,
modern look, a modern face,
a central place for people
to go for all their needs
and requirements as a job
seeker within the state.
So that's the modernizing.
The second pillar is
around new innovations.
Can we bring machine learning
and artificial intelligence
to job searches?
Can we help with
resume-building or resume
parsing, where we can actually
take keywords out of a resume
and match those to certain
jobs, more of in a clustering
machine learning model rather
than just a raw keyword search?
We also looked at chat
bots and the ability
to take some of the load
off the call centers
in states and utilizing
natural language processing
to help guide job seekers
and answer questions.
So and we looked at a number
of those types of innovations.
The third pillar in the
Virtual Career Center
is around taking what was a
brick-and-mortar, physical
career center and
putting that online
and doing it
virtually using Google
Meet and other
technologies to create
a virtual version of
what was happening
in those physical
career centers.
So far, every state
we've talked to, they
tend to choose different things.
It's interesting, because you
think they all need the same--
they have the same needs.
But their own history,
their technology savviness,
the needs of their
constituents--
it tends to vary.
And so we find different
commissioner stakeholders,
different states--
they need different pieces.
And that's why it's nice
to be able to put out
a-- we always call it the menu.
We tell states, you
can order off the menu.
And depending what you
order, obviously, they
have prices, just like a menu.
And so that's how we work
through budgets and solutions
with them.
And it's been interesting
to see different states.
So beyond just
state governments,
we've actually had some
interesting opportunities
to talk about the Virtual Career
Center and the technologies
and the solution
with some counties,
with some other countries,
and a number of universities.
Everywhere you've got
people looking for jobs,
or people looking for
additional training,
or looking to better
their careers,
there's an opportunity in
the Virtual Career Center.
AGV: Well, thank you,
Joel, for walking us
through so much great
information about your journey
today.
To wrap up and leave
on a positive note,
what was a memorable
moment you experienced?
JOEL OSMAN: One of the
things that I have said
is, throughout the pandemic--
I think for me personally, and
I think for a lot of the team--
we're not frontline workers.
We're not health care workers.
We're not grocery store workers.
And we were along for the
ride, in some respects,
during this whole thing.
And so being able to
be part of a solution
that is doing our part--
we may be on the IT side of it.
But just being able to
do something in our field
to help people's
lives get better,
to help people find jobs
coming out of the pandemic,
get a job that maybe they
lost to the pandemic,
it really felt
like doing our part
versus being on the sidelines
through this whole crisis.
AGV: Ah yes.
This work is quite meaningful.
And I think it's
an epic milestone
to be able to scale
operations to a virtual format
in this way, which speaks to the
beauty of building in the cloud
and designing for a
positive user experience.
Well friends, I left
several helpful links
in this video's
description in case
you want to check them out.
If you like this
type of content,
then feel free to
watch more episodes
on architecting in Google Cloud
or subscribe to the channel.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]